her home editor jason farrell joined
this new team called medic 3 as they
raced through london on life-saving
missions his reports contained some
flashing images
take the next left
air ambulance staff don't always travel
by helicopter in london it's not
possible after dark
follow the road around to the right
another misconception is that they're
designed to quickly shift people back to
hospital
and then in 300 meters we'll be turning
right
but this is expertise racing to the sea
john and sam hope that they can save
lives on the spot
mileage was 11.3 we are patient side
we've arrived at a road traffic accident
hi guys
i'm john this is sam just coming to one
of the paramedics wiggle your toes
yep and where does it hurt here there
you go it was thought a patient was
having breathing difficulties but in
fact he's okay and can be looked after
by the ambulance staff roughly about one
in a thousand calls will have um
will have the need
for an advanced trauma team and these
are patients that either won't survive
to hospital
or will do significantly worse without
the advanced interventions that we can
bring a most common call sadly in london
is uh shootings and stabbings so what we
call penetrating trauma continue
straight on these lights
what happens next is two jobs come in
almost at once
when the road splits you'll be taking
the left hand fork straight on across
london two lives hang in the balance
100 second exit 12 o'clock before now
london's air ambulance only had one
vehicle operating at night and would
have to choose but with this new team
one can go to a stabbing in east london
while we head towards someone who's had
a dangerous fall it's estimated this one
extra team could save hundreds of lives
this winter
yeah
it's a serious head injury the street
emergency room is set up i think i'll
get her straight for the tube if you
chuck us
we've agreed not to show anything that
might identify the patient but early
intervention is done she's taken to
hospital on what's called a code black a
full trauma team is waiting in surgery
john provides care in the ambulance and
sam follows the ambulance [ __ ] scene was
all doing a fantastic job when we got
there but she was unconscious and she
was so deeply unconscious that she
actually wasn't managing to maintain her
own airway so she needed intubation she
needed an anesthetic outside of hospital
which is something that the road
ambulance is not able
to give her
this is the most stressful job i've
observed they negotiate london with the
skill of rally drivers then immediately
switched to lifesavers
and sadly in this case john had the
added burden of telling family members
the patient wasn't going to make it you
do your job and you're there for the
patient you're there for that patient's
family but you take some of it home with
you because you have to give a little
bit of yourself when you talk to these
families and you look after these
patients because otherwise you're not
doing the job right
and that layers up over time and i think
one of the things about covid in this
last 20 months in healthcare has been
all everybody's having these things but
no one's had that time to process and
release that pressure
but life goes on
and so does saving lives
the next call could come at any moment
ready to go again
jason farrell sky news